turning overseas North Korea's state
media announced overnight that Kim
jong-un plans to hold off from launching
missiles at Guam at least for now the US
military is ready to defend the
territorial any attack Secretary of
Defense James mater said we know within
moments where it's going if they fire at
the United States they that could
escalate into war very quickly if they
do that it's game on been traces
following this unfolding story from
Seoul South Korea
then good morning good morning it's a
holiday known as liberation day here in
South Korea as well as across the border
in North Korea some pop this might be an
opportunity for Kim Jong Un's who
launched another missile or take some
sort of provocative act instead he seems
to be signaling he's ready to
de-escalate this conflict with the u.s.
these pictures from North Korean state
media show Kim jong-un reviewing
military plans with his generals to
launch four missiles near the island of
Guam the North Korean leader decided not
to immediately launch his weapons but
did launch another war of words at the
u.s. he said if the Yankees persist in
their extremely dangerous reckless
actions on the Korean Peninsula North
Korea's military will ring the windpipes
and point daggers at their necks the
real threat is a North Korean missile
capable of hitting the u.s. after
several failed missile tests in 2016
North Korea has now successfully built
and launched two intercontinental
ballistic missiles despite heavy
international sanctions to do it so
quickly is is quite astonishing Mikell
element is a missile expert who has
closely studied North Korea's
capabilities for years
he says the regime's sudden advancements
mean it received some sort of help
there's just a limited number of
countries which actually can produce
something of this size and capability
and through a series of deductions and
an elimination of possibilities you come
to either Russia or Ukraine element
believes that the engines used on North
Korea's ha song missiles first launched
in May came from a factory in Ukraine
and were then likely transported by
train through Russia to North Korea
those missile advancements
Vin's China North Korea's main trading
partner to go along with tough new UN
sanctions on Monday China banned all
imports of North Korean coal iron ore
and seafood here in Seoul today the
president of South Korea moon jae-in had
pretty direct words saying that war is
not an option on the Korean Peninsula
and that no other country has a right to
start one here without South Korea's
consent Ben Tracy reporting in Seoul
then thank you